I started working in Northern Ireland
the best part of 20 years ago now
when there was a big piece of work to
build the Police Service of Northern
Ireland up to make sure that it
reflected both communities and that it
complied with human rights as sort of
core element of policing and so I was
here for five years at Northern Ireland
working with the policing board on that
project and therefore in Derry many many
times
enjoying working on that project talking
to communities talking to police
officers here and getting to know
Northern Ireland in a really really deep
way in and for me I've always loved the
people of Northern mind I think
everybody who actually spends any time
here always will and so much did I enjoy
those five years of being here that when
I got married in the first year we got
married I brought my wife here because I
kept talking to her about Northern
Ireland and so in the year we were
married
um we came here in the first August we
were married and flew into Belfast got a
small all car in Belfast and then spent
three weeks driving literally around the
whole of the island of Ireland including
here through Derry and so that my wife
could appreciate what was going on about
when I kept saying this amazing place in
all night you need to come and see the
people the friends I've made the
colleagues and then see the rest of
Ireland it was fantastic and then I
think we were last here Sarah when we
were together
um a year and a bit maybe in the best
part of two years ago now when I think
we've just come out of lockdown and so I
was back over here when we were over on
Peace Bridge which was really really
incredible and what I took
um from my time in Northern Ireland was
really important because we all are
asked particularly in politicians here
what made a difference to you what
shaped you you know which bits of what
you've done in your life really changed
your thinking for me my five years and
all night it really really changed my
thinking for a number of reasons I'd
been a lawyer an advocate and as a law
and Advocate you'll very often fight
editing the system you're taking
individual cases you're trying to
challenge people to change and that's a
really good thing of amazing lawyers
human rights lawyers who've done
fantastic work coming to Northern
Ireland was my first opportunity to work
on the inside with the police to say
well let's not Challenge on the outside
let's see whether we can work on the
inside and change things in a different
way but it also exposed me to the very
many people across Northern Ireland who
were courageous who were resilient who
were absolutely determined to do the
difficult things to bring about change
to do something which actually given the
history was very difficult which is how
do I walk in somebody else's shoes how
do I actually bravefully do that
individual Collective acts of courage
and resilience and that was really
inspiring for me to see you know the big
things but also the little things that
people were doing to try to move things
forward and I found it a period of great
hope and change in Northern Ireland even
in the five years I was coming things
changed so much and even every time I
come back now I see even more change
going on that hope and that change for
the future and this year is an important
year for Hope and change because not
only have we got the protocol which as
you will have seen was unveiled this
week my party is supporting the protocol
I think it's an important step in the
right direction and I hope that we can
make progress of course it'll take time
quite rightly but I do think we can step
forward and it is the 25th anniversary
of a good Friday
agreement one of the greatest
achievements I think politically
of you know many political parties but
for my political party we is one of the
proudest things of the last Labor
government when people say to me what
difference it makes have a labor
government what did you do when you were
last in power The Good Friday agreement
is right up there on my list of the
things that we are proud of having I've
done so it's a really important year and
it is a year for looking back and
reflecting on the incredible change the
incredible bravery that there was in
signing that agreement and making it
work but also looking to the next 25
years and bringing with it that sense of
hope and change because we will go
through this year and we'll go into next
year and next year
we will undoubtedly have a general
election and that's a big moment
um for the United Kingdom a really
really big moment
um and you know I feel very strongly and
you'd expect me to say this after 13
years of I think failure of not moving
forward in the way that we should have
done 13 years of finding points of
division rather than points of unity 13
years of missing opportunities to really
take the United Kingdom forward I think
and I hope next year we get the chance
to say to the electorate do you want to
carry on with this manage decline or do
you want to move forward with something
else that hope and change and it will be
hope and change because I don't want a
labor government
just to come in and manage things a
little bit better maybe than the
government we've had for the last 13
years I want to allow the government to
come in and to change things and to give
people a sense of hope and how we're
going forward so you can say actually
you know what this is something that can
help and shape me and then therefore
what I wanted to talk about this morning
is how does that affect you as young
people here in Northern Ireland my
strong view is that if we're going to
change and change for the better we have
to have a government that's completely
focused and is able to say these are the
things that we want to achieve in
government and I've called it missions a
sort of mission-led government a real
sense of driving purpose we don't need
government because we like being in
government we're not in power because we
like being in power we're in for a
purpose which is to change things for
the better and there are a number of
things I really think need changing and
the first one is
um economic growth growing our economy
and by that I mean driving up living
standards and more than driving up
living stands making sure that
everywhere people feel the benefit of
that I often feel and you may feel this
there's there's a sense sometimes people
have that if I've got a if I've got to
get old I need to get out from where I
am and I think that destroys communities
and places and so I want an economy that
drives forward I think here in Northern
Ireland Colin and I were talking about
this this morning uh perhaps and this is
just a seed of a thought for all of you
as we reflect on the last 25 years this
year has been able to do perhaps we
should also be saying well what about
the next 25 years then what what does
that mean economically
um for Northern Ireland how we drive
that forward so that in 20 years when
somebody else is probably standing here
talking to the next generation of
students so what we did in the last 20
years in terms of driving those living
standards up so that's one of the things
we absolutely want to drive towards I
think I make a big big difference here
you know is it infrastructure is it as
it trains how do we get those businesses
fantastic businesses and very Pete came
here Peter Kyle came here and saw some
of the brilliant things that are going
on in some of the businesses here so
that technology that Innovation is all
all here another big driving mission is
obviously we've got to have a Health
Service that's fit for the future the
moment of Health Service which every
winter goes through a crisis I mean
every winter we put a sticking plaster
on it and then we just about breathe in
the summer and then we get back into a
crisis for the next winter can't keep
going on like that we need a Health
Service fit for the future and it's got
to
other physical health and mental health
and I know that for many of the young
people here I think when you had your
school council one of the issues you
raised was the mental health of students
of young people in this school and I
think I'm right and saying you've got
mental health mentors who help with that
and I think that's one of the big issues
as we go forward as is climate change
you know we've got an obligation in
relation to the climate to preserve our
planet for you and for the generation
that come behind you which is a heavy
heavy responsibility but it's also a
fantastic opportunity it would be
brilliant jobs of the future
in the change that we have to go through
in order to make our climate work
another one of course is Safety and
Security you don't need me to tell you
how important that is if we don't have
that basic security and peace and space
for you to flourish it is hard to
flourish and therefore that has to be a
central driving mission of any
government and then the fifth thing is
opportunity for every child every young
person everywhere and the everywhere is
really important in all of this because
quite often when we talk about growing
the economy or opportunities we talk too
much about one particular place you know
it'll happen in London all the big
cities we've got to make sure it's a
trust all of the United Kingdom across
all of Northern Ireland I think the huge
huge opportunities so you know this is a
time for me to enjoy being here I'd much
prefer being here by the way the big in
Parliament okay the days we are Monday
Tuesday Wednesday we're in Parliament
ending with prime minister's questions
about 12 o'clock the best part of the
week is about 12 30 when we finish pmqs
and I can leave Parliament then and get
out and talk to you and communities and
get across the United Kingdom